let's get going with this newshour
beginning with some breaking news coming
to us out of mali where the military
say the president and the prime minister
have been arrested in what could be
a coup it started as a mutiny among
soldiers in the town of katie
about 15 kilometers from the capital
bamako
pictures on twitter are said to show two
cars
carrying president ibrahim bubakakita
and the prime minister
bubu sisi other video has also shown
protesters have been calling for mr
keita to quit celebrating in bamako
ahmed idris is following developments
from the nigerian capital
abuja for us here on the newshour ahmed
nice to talk to you again what's the
latest information we have
well basically the information we have
right now is that
um the the yeah the the the information
that
president obama and the prime minister
have been arrested
and they are currently on their way or
right now
inside the catty camp which is
effectively under the control of the
mutineers
um early on like you like we said we
they have arrested
senior ministers in government the
foreign minister the finance minister
speaker of parliament and other senior
officials and
senior military chopras if these people
are in fact
in the hands of the mutineers then
effectively
it's a coup no longer a mutiny because
they have all the powers to negotiate
they can negotiate to form a government
they can also negotiate
for their for our way out with anybody
who is interested in negotiations but
it doesn't look like they are interested
in negotiations report we're getting
right now out of bamako
is that probably the military will make
an announcement shortly
at um at eight o'clock local time which
is around
20 gmt so we wait to see whether or not
that happens
and what the military will say now right
now what we know
is that governments around the world
have condemned the
the coup uh coup or mutiny as it is
the united states we had some from
france we also had the echoes the
regional block and the african union
condemning it as a an attempt to
unconstitutionally overthrow a
government we need to see what
the next uh line of action of these
countries will be
we know already the sanctions they apply
on member states
especially the african union and the
economic community of west african
states
that execute a coup on a militar
civilian government and the punishment
actually is
to ostracize them to take them out of
the
union as well as impose some economic
and political sanctions
so we wait to see what if this is indeed
a coup
we wait to see what these uh
organizations and institutions
will do in the next few days i suppose
ahmed it is fair to say it doesn't
really matter whether this
is being perpetrated by all of the
malian military
or a large percentage of the malian
military but whoever's leading this
so far it looks like a coup whoever's
leading this do we know what it was that
if you will push that person over the
edge and decided do this and do it today
yes of course earlier on there were
there were reports that the colonel was
in charge of this but it is yet to be
confirmed
and if this happens uh definitely with
the top military
uh officers now in the hands of the
meetings it's going to be much much
easier for them
to do whatever they want to set up a
government uh
to maybe install an interim government
or even negotiate if things get
out of control for them uh with the
regional bodies like echoes and the
african union
but one important thing to note is that
this
can lead to total chaos we've seen this
happen in 2012
when uh president ahmadu to manipulate
was pushed out of power
by military by the military uh over the
situation in the north of mali when the
torah rebels
launched a rebellion there now what we
know
is that there is an increase in activity
by armed groups
al-qaeda the islamic state and other
various armed groups in the north of
mali
and the border with burkina faso niger
and and all these places they will
exploit any political or military vacuum
that is there to launch more aggressive
attacks they will be the happiest
people with these developments now in
bamako
so we want what we probably will see
in the next few days will be more
attacks because the
armed groups have realized that the
security situation in mali is fluid now
uh what probably people will be looking
up to
uh is the presence of the international
forces the french the united nations and
other regional powers that deployed
their
troops to mali to keep the peace ahmed
do stay close keep us posted we'll come
back to you if needs be but in the
meantime thank you very much
well these developments do bear a stark
resemblance to the events leading up to
mali's military coup eight
years ago that's when soldiers seized
power from the then
president amado to manitoure a
transitional government later took over
and organized elections which the
current
president mr keita won but the political
turmoil
unleashed years of chaos allowing
fighters to seize towns in the north of
the country
keita has faced growing condemnation
about his perceived inability to tackle
those armed groups joining us on the
line now from
bamako is idrissa sanger a political
analyst
and journalist addressa sanger give us a
sense
of where you are and what you've been
seeing and hearing
actually i'm outside in bamako you know
i've been uh i was going to cathy to see
what's happening
exactly at this time but i find
the the military convoy coming down in
bamako so i follow them
they go through uh to the straight to
the
national public radio so i can't
go i can't follow them inside but we are
maybe expecting some some something come
out uh
in a few hours a few minutes uh
from now explain to us
why the protesters on the streets are
apparently
celebrating a military coup
so you know there is a situation going
on in mali
since uh i can say uh
three or two or three months ago with uh
the
[Music]
you know the the the the religious chief
uh
named the mammoth dico as leading uh
protesting against the regime against
ibrahimovic
regime and they were they are willing to
take them
take down this regime by protecting
outside
in bamako so we can say
these are the people actually
um demonstrating in the
you know the the the these
these people are now rely
uh at the place of independence of
ramako
to scam how they're happy you know to
see the president
ibrahim bubakar keita regime throw down
or overflow so exactly
who is celebrating i can't say but most
of the people
outside celebrating are from the m5
movement the people who are running the
coup
some members are a big number of the
military
we are now reporting what other people
are reporting
saying that they have taken the
president
and the prime minister out of bamako
and he's now arrested or under detention
in kathy why take them to kathy why not
leave them
being held in bamako
you know the county is the camp
uh leading by these two office
officer the officer
i think we've lost that line there to
bamaco we'll give it one more go adrisa
can you hear me it's peter dobby here in
the studio in doha
hello yes we lost the line there for a
second addressa
please carry on you were explaining you
were explaining to us
why they have taken the president and
the prime minister to cathy
okay so there is two names come out of
kathy
the the colonel maki zhao and colonel
sergio camara
both of these guys are acting uh with
the military
deployed inside bamako to to take
control
so this is what we got
this morning when we go to katie but
while taking the president
and held him in kathy inside they come
they want
to be sure the president is under they
control
in fact we we are waiting for an
official announcement people are saying
uh
the president has been arrested but the
military the military the malian
military doesn't uh
tells us if something is going on
why do you think i've been artists okay
pardon me for
interrupting you there address so that
the line has got a bit of a delay on it
and i apologize for that
what do you think the military will do
with
the president and the prime minister and
these other
government officials who they've
arrested
i can't say exactly what but there is a
lot of possibility
they are they will heal them to to to
negotiate
if there is a negotiation going on with
you and
with some african organization
who will try to free president tbika
even if he will not remain in power but
they will try to free him
to to secure his life and official
government too
so they heal these uh people
to to to to to in
in views of all negotiations coming uh
in a few days or in a few minutes maybe
okay adrissa sanger thank you so much
for coming on to al jazeera to talk to
us
and uh as the dresser was mentioning
there there is a lot of speculation that
we are
in the next couple of hours going to see
or hear some of an announcement from the
military in
mali ahmed idris was paying lip service
to this as well
it's apparently going to happen at 20
hours gmt so that's in what an hour and
45.
as soon as we have access to that we'll
bring it to you here on al jazeera more
reaction coming in all the time
from the russian deputy foreign minister
michael bogdanoff
saying they've received information
about the arrests of the malian
president and the prime minister that's
according to the
ria news agency he also said that moscow
is concerned about the events
in mali
you